Humans and horses have had a strong connection
for generations.
But that connection may be even stronger than
we thought.
Hey animal lovers, Lissette here for DNews.
When I was a little girl, I wanted a pony.
They’re so beautiful and majestic, but today
science is telling us they’re also pretty
smart.
In a recent study published in the journal
Biology Letters, researchers found that horses
can distinguish between different human facial
expressions.
They were able to figure this out by showing
the horses photographs of either angry or
happy male faces and then noting the horses’
responses.
When the horses were presented with an angry
face, they exhibited left-gaze bias.
This basically means that the horses turned
their heads to look more with their left eye
towards the right side of the face on the
photograph.
When they were presented with a happy face,
they didn’t express this same bias.
In the case of the horses, this left-gaze
bias with the angry faces versus the happy
human faces, showed that they could detect
a difference between these two human expressions.
Left-gaze bias is also used to study emotions
in both humans and animals, and although it
may vary by species, some studies have shown
emotions are perceived as more prominently
expressed on the right side of a person’s
face.
So, as you might guess, animals detecting
different human facial expressions isn’t
something new…
According to research, other animals like
dogs and pigeonscan distinguish between faces
and expressions.
Researchers at the University of Iowa, found
that pigeons can see similarities among human
faces when it comes to identity and emotion.
Essentially, the pigeons could tell when the
photographs they were shown were of the same
person and when the emotions of different
people were similar.
And, the research on dogs is particularly
robust.
In one study, researchers at Azabu University,
found dogs could learn to pick out photographs
of smiling human faces from those with blank
expressions.
And researchers from Kyoto University showed
that dogs can match their owner’s face to
their owner’s voice.
Furthermore, a study on 22 dogs from the University
of Lincoln showed a very similar result to
the horse study.
The dogs more strongly exhibited a left-gaze
bias when they looked at negative facial expressions
than positive ones.
So if this dog study shows a similar result
to this new horse study, what makes it so
special?
Well, because in addition to measuring the
horses’ external physical reactions, researchers
also collected internal data - specifically
their heart rate.
The horses’ heart rates accelerated at different
rates depending on whether the faces shown
were angry or happy ones.
As one of the researchers explains, “The
reaction to the angry facial expressions was
particularly clear -- there was a quicker
increase in their heart rate."
Which is huge!
According to the researchers, this makes it
the first in all animal studies to show a
differential heart rate response to human
facial expressions.
It suggests that on top of recognizing the
difference between what the two facial expressions
look like, the horse might know what the angry
expression means.
A rapidly increasing heart rate is associated
with threatening situations.
Again, to quote one of the study’s researchers,
“in this context, recognising angry faces
may act as a warning system, allowing horses
to anticipate negative human behaviour such
as rough handling.”
This makes sense as horses are highly social
animals, and emotional awareness is helpful
to the functioning and survival of highly
social groups.
Now, as one of the researchers points out,
we can’t conclude from this research that
horses evolved an ability to recognize human
faces because of co-evolution with humans
or if each individual horse simply learned
how to read faces during its own lifetime.
Or it could be because of something else.
But what’s clear is that horses may be more
clued into our emotions than we think.
Maybe horses should be man’s best friend?
What do you think?
Let us know in the comments below and remember
to subscribe to DNews.
So if some animals can recognize our emotions,
does this mean they can also feel some of
the same emotions we do?
Check out this episode on whether animals
can empathize to find out